so right-wing dude Charlie Kirk put out  a list of priorities for the Republican  party and they're all completely  pathetic he uh the the things he lists  are number one defund the 87 000 IRS  agents they never want to tell you this  but 55 000 of the 87 000 IRS agents are  retiring over the next decade and 55 000  of those are just to replace people who  are retiring it's like a marginal  increase to the IRS Force the helists  impeach majorcus and Garland uh why  there's no reason to do that investigate  and reconstitute the FBI they're just  mad that Trump had a search warrant  served saved the military from the wokes  the military is fine block Government  funding on everything until the border  is secure almost nothing has changed at  the border since Biden took over in  Peach Biden why and election Integrity  which means make it easier for them to  steal elections when they lose this is a  pathetic set of priorities my friend